you got an issue
[Music]
not only do we need to defund but we
need to dismantle and start anew perhaps
we can
shuffle some of that money around we
need to defund the police and put that
money into social safety nets
the community is actually asking where
are our police officers
we want the police officers in the
community
there isn't a single community that i've
gone into where they've said nah you
know what we don't want more police we
want more social workers to come in they
do want social workers to come in but
they also want to feel safe
[Music]
there can be a very vicious cycle
involving police efforts to solve
homicides
which under circumstances last year and
into this year meant that the police
were solving fewer homicides
as a result community confidence in the
effectiveness of the police
the very likely decreases
and as community confidence in the
police decreases we might expect
homicides to go up increasing the
caseload making it more difficult for
the police to solve homicides
the murder of george floyd in
minneapolis sparked a legitimacy crisis
it mobilized people's opinions about the
police
almost immediately thereafter
demonstrations broke out across the
country against police violence the
social justice movement and the defund
the police movement it was taken very
seriously by our council and the numbers
of police officers that we have today
are reflected as such we are in a
resource-constrained environment
gallup recorded the lowest confidence in
police that it had ever recorded since
since it started tracking that in 93
when the police lack legitimacy in the
public eye they become less willing to
cooperate with the police in the form of
reporting crimes reporting suspicious
activities helping them do their jobs
the number one factor in whether a
homicide will be cleared is the
availability of a cooperative witness
and in some homicide cases there is no
available cooperative witness
i imagine that's very frustrating when
you feel like you know you've got the
offender but nobody even though they
were there they won't talk to you
unfortunately in some communities that
suffer from very high rates of homicide
there's also a corresponding lack of
trust in police both for the failure to
protect community members from homicide
and because of perhaps past police
misconduct against members of that
community and frankly over time there
can be cynicism both among the community
members and among the cops themselves
about the solvability of these crimes
and i think it's very important that we
try to push back on that cynicism as
much as possible
[Music]
there was this national movement of
distrust in police and reduced the
police and communities the interesting
thing that we've seen over this year as
our homicide
rates have gone where they've gone
is the community is actually not in that
same place
the community is actually asking where
are our police officers
we want the police officers in the
community
there isn't a single community that i've
gone into where they've said nah you
know what we don't want more police we
want more social workers to come in they
do want social workers to come in but
they also want to feel safe
we did see a major rise in homicide the
homicide rise in so many places was so
abrupt and it began
just about a day or two
after george floyd was killed
departments simply aren't able to adapt
as rapidly as the homicides are going up
and then if you add in the pandemic and
depletion in police ranks that makes
solution even more difficult our violent
crime reduction unit and our gun
recovery unit those two major units
that's been a challenge over the last
couple years in retention based on
everything that's going on in the
country and the general sentiment around
police as well as our ability to hire
across the country generally but
especially in communities that are
hardest hit by high homicide rates there
is this hopelessness that there's really
nothing that can be done and that it is
this chronic problem that is beyond sort
of solving
fortunately that's not the case
you know this year we're bad numbers
compared to years past year in the
district of columbia
but i also look at all the things that
we've done the things that we've been
able to accomplish and it could have
been a heck of a lot worse
there were three areas in the city where
there were 13 plus warrants that were
served within a very short period of
time and in all those areas we saw 60
percent reduction or more in violent
crime that lasted three to four months
and some still going on the mayor's made
her almost 60 million dollar investment
in our prevention side which is going to
have effect over the next year 18 months
to two years affecting those numbers too
i think
not satisfied not happy with the outcome
but i do think it could have been a heck
of a lot worse